I'm one of the core maintainers of
matplotlib and as some of you may have
known about a year ago we promised you
we'd get Matt Pollock 2.0 with improved
defaults and you know this is half a
half a apology talk half of this is what
we've done talk so it turns out that
changing of the defaults was harder than
we thought it would be so just a little
bit of detail by the way first where we
have done.i one point five point three
release which is the bug fix release for
the current the current series pull
through this should be the last version
this was tagged this was tagged about a
week ago
it's on Pippy it's on it's not gone to
forge it should make it into the
standard distribution packages in the
near future so for 2.0 we are in fact
almost year late we estimated September
last year we started doing betas we're
currently in beta for which you can
install using either pip or Conda via
these commands so I and I'm running this
notebook off of environment which has
beta 4 installed so you could you know
in principle you can run all everything
I'm about to show you for the future the
plan always has been that as soon as you
got to point out the door we were going
to do a 2.1 very quickly with some
pretty limited goals although due to our
previous estimation you should not trust
that I when I say a 3 to 6 months but
the the the big goals there's we want to
base the library on trail it's so a lot
of this configuration will become easier
interaction with ipython widgets will
become a lot easier because they speak
the same language and we should that
should provide a reasonable path to
serializing figures and possibly a path
to interchangeable they're plotting
libraries and something we had a google
Summer of Code student do this summer
Hannah did for us was
and if I have time I'll show at the end
as we now have categorical plotting she
passes a list of strings will do the
right thing to plot those as categories
and that's currently on master branch so
we're excited to get that out as soon as
we can
somewhat longer term we plan to it at
sci fi 2018 tag the last release the
last version of MATLAB which will
support Python to seven we find the Keen
bug fixes for that until 2020 when
Python stopped supporting to seven and
these two links the first one is the
pitch for why you should switch to
Python 3 and all the the nice features
you get as a sign yeah from the science
side of what why it's worth the effort
to net did you know and the second one
is most the major projects have agreed
that by 2020 we'll have at least one
Python 3 only release so if you have not
started the conversion yet I encourage
you to start as soon as possible the
sooner you do it the less painful it
will be
so the the obvious meme given the talk
title we really thought we could just
change some things in the RC params
change the default values maybe we'd
have one or two corner cases something
we have to discuss to take a month might
drop whom was the other Kohli developer
came up to New York we spent a day
sitting in a conference room and instead
of just changing the defaults we found
the first was dragon infested rabbit
holes that you you start going down them
and then instead of you know getting and
finding rabbit you find out you're
having dragon that tries to take your
head off and we just kept finding these
everywhere we looked so the as a side
effect of this we've actually cleaned a
tremendous amount of technical debt out
of the library this isn't necessary if
we'd been here this is not how we would
have planned to do it if we had planned
so one of the a feature that went in in
math 1.4
which is going to be relying on very
heavily going forward is the style
module which has all of the style about
use and this will go out and basically
get a style sheet or which is really
the Narcy Browns file that applies
Styles differentially on top of what
your current RC programs are so if you
so if you do classic we're currently
running the tests on the 2.0 branch
getting basically pixel identical
results on the 2-point x branch to the
test that we were running previously so
if you do not like the style team to be
made or for whatever reason you need the
old styles exactly as they were you
throw the single line at the top of your
script and you will get back your old
results so fault so this is these are
the new defaults just some quick things
that you should notice off the top we've
moved the ticks now point out instead of
in we've removed the ticks from the top
the left and the right we've changed the
rules and how we do auto scaling
previously we would try to get you know
nice round numbers as your limits now
it's 5% on your data range the lines a
little thicker and the line width is a
little thicker compared to what it was
before also this is the style module can
be used to all we ship with a number of
other style sheets such as if you're
using Seaborn purely for the Styles you
can just put this the top of your script
and you get the you get all that styling
without having to pick up all the
patient defendants things that come with
Seaborn we ship with a couple I'm gonna
go back to the default is for the rest
of the talk
right oh I guess other thing if yes this
looks slightly different than in line
this is actually a live interactive
figure that I can pan and sew around in
this has actually been in since 1.4 but
no one seems to know you can use it I
guess I probably should put that line I
thought this
if you just use that instead of in line
you will get live interactive figures in
the notebook and this has the complete
event handling you'd expect in the GUI
notebook we capture key events mass
events scroll events so anything you
want a program against is there all
right so this is the list of the style
sheets we ship with if you have a
particular style you like that we don't
have
we're very liberal taking pull requests
to add style sheets and the way we look
this up there's a there's a in the
configuration folder if you add your own
style sheets with the correct name will
automatically discover them and so if
you have a corporate style that you want
to put some place on a Jupiter hub make
sure everyone has it you can use this
mechanism to enforce a consistent style
or twelve out of a consistent style
across across all your teams so one of
the most obvious changes is thanks so
we've we've changed the default color
cycle the original colors were RGB CMYK
which is oddly similar to the the seven
colors you get from the be printing
wheels so we've used the Vega palette
ten color cycle which is what's shown on
the right there and if you notice they
down here you can see what the hex
values of them are and unlike previously
when we had nice single letter
shorthands for the for these colors for
the hexes we have these as far as I know
these colors don't have names and they
definitely don't have single character
names so to make this reasonable to work
with we also added this notation if you
see on the left it says c0 to c9 so what
this is is when we when we evaluate the
color string if we see C and then a
single integer we go to the default
property cycle which I will is the next
slide and pull the color out from the
end
in that cycle so now I so this is
pulling out c2 and c3 which in which are
greenish and reddish if we change this
to come on
she's the Seabourn you see the colors
have changed to the to the second and
third colors are X the third and fourth
colors and the C brown color cycle so
this is a way that if you're if you are
going to do work with with use the style
module to change your default color
cycle regularly you can write your
colors in a way that will remain
consistent with whatever style sheet you
choose to use and you can see this is
any place that we expect a color like
input you can pass one of these strings
and it's also valid in the the Styles
the string style specification that plot
takes alright so before I get to the the
the prop cycle I'm gonna take a small
detour off into cycler this is a project
that we spun out of map out live core
for the 1.5 release and basically what
it is is thin wrappers around intervals
of dictionaries and itertools so you see
this is the night you they have a nice a
nice notebook representation if I add
two of them together I get the best
ideas in ritual zip if you do
multiplication you get the outer product
between them so this is a virtual
product and this just provides a way to
provide your sequences in a name but if
you then go right over them give you out
dictionaries with the correct values in
them the start is a pull request of
matplotlib
and then a number of people said they
wanted to use the separate map while
loop so it's its own project the docks
are hosted here and just to see it in
action
so this is thank you you still see the
usage here sorry you know this this was
this is the intended use case but
actually it can be expanded much more so
for instance you want you have a list of
data you need to loop over if you zip a
cycler with your your list of data you
cannot very easily do interesting
faceted things and or consistently style
things if you had this you know more
than one time than having to write all
the six nested for-loops yourself so
which brings up to in 1.5 we deprecated
color ax dot color cycle and replaced it
with prop cycle which takes one of these
secular objects and this still right oh
I forgot to change back to defaults
so this is just you uh this is just
plotting ten lines going you're just
using the default style cycling if I
change this to a plus C just goes the
red and green without the line list
coupled and if I do that you see it
ramps first through the line width and
then the color in sequence so you
there's many you can use this to express
very common your interesting style
cycles pretty tersely okay many more
things and to point out follow the the
property cycle then used to for example
by popular demand scatter now it follows
the property cycle if we flip back to
classic you see they're all blue and you
get three dots in the legend
whereas with but the new defaults you
get every cycle and the legends down to
a single dot and if you look closely
oh yeah so that the legend now defaults
to going to the best positions that have
always the upper right which is a coming
requested thing if you look there then
actually has some default alpha in it so
if it doesn't really your data it's very
clear it's very clear so overlaying your
data but you can still you know see it a
little bit right so another common
requested thing it would was to scale
the - patterns with the line width for
example so if you look at this you can
see that the the pattern is getting a
scaling proportionally go aligned with
if we go back to the
laughter classic mode you see how that
you know because the dot stay the same
width as your belonging us wider they
turn from dots to these funny dashi
things and this was a this was a
particularly interesting rabbit hole you
know we thought was just changing we
added like one line of code and it it
seemed to work and then we discovered
some you know horrendous consequences
from that and you know eight hours later
it was working again but it was this was
not one we expected to give us trouble
and that did something else that we have
that again some of this was in earlier
versions we know so for 1.5 we added the
data quark so all the plot method they
see all the plotting functions and
methods on the axis object will now take
a data quark and if you pass that an
object that supports and get item with
strings and returns to you something
that is kind of like a numpy array you
can then write your plotting in like
this
where you pass the keys into this object
in for the where you'd normally put in
the arrays and then internally will do
that will do that the referencing for
you so this is a commonly requested as
nearest to write more readable cursor
codes the other option this would be a B
D F square bracket th close square
bracket comma and you want you know if
you need to pass in two or three of
these you will end up with you know your
name of your data frame every one of
those places and this isn't one five so
if you're keeping up to date like you
have this on your computer right now
and it works with dictionaries it works
with H five by objects yeah again
anything that supports a get item on a
string is the only API required we have
on that and you notice there's a list
works it was it picked I didn't pass
label in here and pick that up
on its own and something else we've
actually we've started to put in some
hooks to support pandas better a little
better natively so if you look at this
data frame the index is 0 to 2 pi I've
got one column in it which is data and
if we just do plot
data and with a legend you'll see it
correctly plotted against the index and
it picked up the name of this column as
data and correctly a label this artist
so if you if you do a lot of pandas data
plotting many of the default you know
all of the default for building map
hollow functions now interact with it
much better so if you if you want to
drop down from the you know the the the
plotting methods attached to the data
frames to lower level stuff it now the
tools to do that are a little easier to
work with all right so one of the the
biggest and most physical changes as the
default color map is no longer jet
please never use jet ever ever if you
don't believe me Nathaniel Smith and
Stefan Vanderbilt gave an extremely good
talk as Syfy last year you can look it
up on YouTube it's linked to from our
Docs explaining everything that's wrong
with jet and the significant amount of
perception theory that went into
designing beer dismay inferno and plasma
which are the four new color maps that
we added one five so again they're on
your computer right now if you want to
use them and so what this this plot here
is this is from the two of is CM that
they developed as in the process of
developing these color maps we're
showing you you know the color map how
will look putting in black and white how
it would look with various color
blindness and then down here you can the
the map of it through our GB space and
for reference if you look at this
perceptual Delta's are very flat if I
switch this to Chet you can see that as
I all dragging all over the place so
this is plasma which I'm just gonna go
through these quickly
there's just to convince you that I'm
actually technical I'm talking to you
what was the last one magnet plasma so
these are the the for perception of
linear color maps that were developed by
Stefan and Daniel pro this process so
and also for I am sure we've changed the
default interpolation from bilinear
which is what you get over here - this
one actually didn't cause any problems
that was good
so however I am the image processing did
have a particularly scaring dragon in it
so this is a figure rendering with 1/5
you know using various interpolation
methods just on that the same data from
the last slide and if you look up here
and sync and a little bit of my linear
and down irrigation there's this red
there is no red in various so what so
what was going on is that the processing
pipeline are doing for normalizing data
as you take your input data we would
scale is 0 to 1 via whatever noir method
you want to use we would then color map
that to our GBA space at your at full
resolution and then reduce AG to down
sample that to our GPA to fill your
screen the problem with this is that
we're doing this we're doing that last
resampling in RGB space which if your
color maps aren't linear in RGB space
that you off the color map and we never
noticed this before because the default
color map was jet and you look at Jen
you said that looks fine there's a bunch
of funny colors there so to fix this
bike completely rewrote the image
handling pipeline like basically you
know and the new pipeline is we take
your input we normalize it then we
resample it to screen size and then once
we have that down down or up sample
version as needed at the last the last
step of rendering is to map at our BG
which we then use subs played at the
screen
so we say like you know part changes and
falls like we found a very significant
book that had just been there for 15
years so sorry another change that this
is not being nice right so I'm going to
run this and then I'm going to delete
okay this is showing up so we've changed
the default font font we really using
Vera which basically had the lion
characters and that was it we're now
using deja vu which is a derivative of
era so all the land characters are in
fact identical so if you're if you're
relying on anything about Vera it's
still there
however it also adds or you can't see
the best part of this kind of delete
from here so you know ok so just believe
me these inputs are just Unicode strings
in Python 3 if I delete those what oh
sorry I'm forgetting what I'm doing
right so yeah deja boo' adds support for
almost all of the Western phonetic
alphabets you see we have Cyrillic
across the top in this is just this is
just stock defaults now like there's no
funny font mocking mocking or anything
if you got a date right we even see the
full the full list I think it's like
Cyrillic Georgian does have Arabic and
Hebrew but we don't support
right-to-left gets you have to do that
yourself it supports a whole like yeah
it has emojis in it so if you really
want to plot against happy sad and
confused you can do that it has you know
you know some selections random
characters almost all the math symbols
so there are many more things that you
can do without having to go out to math
text you can just use the Unicode and
it'll do the right thing all right and
this is just kind of a fun thing
so I CCD did a color survey
where they asked people what colors were
and ended up with 954 names mapping to
our RBG values we now ship that
dictionary there the names are all
prefixed by ex-ac xkcd it turns out they
can it conflicts very heavily with the
CSS for x11 color names and as much as
we might want to change them map polyp
is not the right place to to push that
particular idea so you know the you know
red blue all those color all the CSS for
color names will get you the CSS for hex
values exactly as CSS defines them but
if you Tec xkcd : on the front you just
type them whatever names from that from
that list that just really amuses me
I hope there's at least one of you and
there's just a scattering of other
things that were that are gonna ship in
2.0 actually the talk ones in 1.5 + 1 5
3 as well if you just switch to if you
just you just are type ipython and ply
plot do peel t2i on it automatically
detects that you're drowning and ipython
and reduce yourself with the event loop
so all of the the interactive activity
should work including an eye Python 5
where they're not using read line and
all of the other fortuitous bindings are
gone so if you have numpy 11 they added
auto to their histogram function which
will automatically figure out what the
correct bins are we'll just we've got
the we'll just pass that through so you
can get automatic bin selection so
something Sylvan crow a has been working
on is so I've been showing um be egg and
that's something or the notebook backend
which is something that we that was
developed well before ipython widgets
had settled down and more stable if I
you could you know program against I
think before they even started we had it
so we're doing a lot of the con work
ourselves and we're just injecting
JavaScript into the notebook Silvan has
gone and embedded you've done the proper
ipython
widget embedding
the project called impl it's currently
available
I think it's available in pick with the
- pre but you need to be using the 2.0
beta to use it because it relies on some
of the changes we made it's part 2.0
lots of documentation z'
the you know some of the web stuff has
correct high DPI support we support QT 5
up to 5 7 extremely well the box refused
black pots the defaults on those have
changed show do you uh I think if your
Mac users the or sex back end has been
significant
and previously we were trying we were
using Mac's native rendering to render
all the glyphs on the figure it's now an
egg-based one as with all the other GUI
backends so blooding works with OS X now
it's faster and that you won't get these
issues where you it looks one way in
your screen you save it to ping and cuz
it's run through entirely different
rendering engine it looks different will
not get the same thing places and I've
seen since you know there's a year of
bug fixes which ends up being quite a
bit but there we go wait how am i doing
on time
great so something that went in in 1:5
that I very much like is if you're
working interactively and then you want
to use that background API to say I
don't know if that's a little too thin
for the screen
I'm making niacin well 55 probably huge
but it automatically refreshes from the
interactive prompt if you're using any
of the object-oriented api's and again
this is on 1/5 so if you're running 1/5
you have on your computer already yeah
again just to show you the the C works
big enough to read probably not so I
don't I think this is super cool it down
definitely this has made my life better
so I hope it makes some of your lives
better
um right so is coming back around or
some housekeeping
we're a non focused officially sponsored
project we're currently in the process
of formalizing our governance we're
modeling the government's after what I
Python and Jupiter is doing if you're
interested matplotlib
slash map all lips / governance is where
as we're doing that there's an open full
request that you can comment on if you
have opinions and we have a very broad
contributor base so using this somewhat
complicated git command you can get a
list of all of the contributors I went
back to January 2015 and if you plot
that cumulate so this is contributor
sorted by number of commits verse the
total number of commits and yeah so
we've got you know a couple core people
down here and if you zoom in up here you
can see a great many people who come by
they give us one commit to commit you
know fixing whatever small bug they
found fixing documentation i'm missin'
you know this is this is a significant
fraction of the work time on map all lip
is done by these very small drive-by
contributions I would say that everyone
stay in this room if you're using MATLAB
on a daily basis
you were qualified to contribute to it
you know starting from something simple
like if you had you're using one of our
functions and it was hard to use and
took you a while to figure out you know
once you understand that like please
take the you know the time you know the
time to fix the dock string and open and
for us to fix the dock string so the
next person doesn't have to go through
that same fight because you know you you
know what you don't understand this
function because you're using it and you
know what words it was missing that
would have helped you understand it
better
so like please do this wheel of
documentation PRS I mean I think I'm a
lot of the exposed API is in Python it's
very it's not there's no deep dark magic
to it it's very its approachable you
know there are unapproachable parsed
library but there's a lot of it that's
very approachable but again if you're
using it daily you're you're you're
almost certainly qualified to make some
contributions I just another thing if we
look at the committers and commits bin
to by week i you see no we got fifty
commits a week it's a very I mean that's
non-trivial and we have you on average
10 unique contributors every week so you
know we're it's definitely an active
healthy project honor if anyone is
worried about that with the many other
falling libraries here all right so well
we we intend to be or we strive to be a
friendly existed community if you do
come into contribution and you feel that
we aren't friendly email me personally
and I will do what I can if you don't
feel comfortable emailing me or I'm the
problem
email numb focus they will do what they
can to fix it you could tell my pitch
earlier we're always looking for new
contributors what oh yeah we have a good
a channel and then kind of more
strategic long-term the use of map polyp
has greatly escaped the domain expertise
of the core developers alright I Mathis
is not fluent cracked my cross miss by
training you do not want me running your
stats plotting function because I don't
know what
what you want them to do right the the
you know the API send those need to be
tuned to the data structures that you
use in your field that need to be tuned
to the you know the kinds of plots you
need to be convenient in your field and
the core library you know in some sense
we're not qualified as in another sense
we can't do that for every sub community
so what we really like to see happen is
we're looking for domain experts experts
to work with us to build domain-specific
plotting libraries we're happy to host
them under our github organization if
you want yeah that's a fair amount of
visibility you get pretty quickly
and you know long-term map only wants to
be the substrate for scientific plotting
not necessarily the end-all be-all
target of you know every end user that
makes sense here something like Seabourn
you know is a tremendously useful
library because it takes care of exactly
a use case that you know Mike Bascom
understands and I do not I mean more
people like that so in closing you know
to thank John Hunter who's the founder
unfortunately passed away and I'm not
you're giving this talk but you know
there there's a you know this is not
there's a tremendous appeal contributor
to this this is my attempt to print out
the list of names I can tell it Scrolls
well off the page and say yeah yeah so
any questions there was a summit last
year at Syfy when this pie was presented
and there were plans to embed this pie
has a rendering engine format blah blah
where's where's that now it's it's still
a good idea it is I mean it's as the tip
of a sort of open source actually so
matplotlib has no FTEs we're almost
entirely volunteer there couples that
might have like near a handful of hours
a week from our day jobs but mostly this
is completely on to your work and
and same thing at this place site that
was a side project and yeah just no
one's had time to work on it the the
conclusions we had from that is
currently you know there's some things
like math clubs architecture do we do a
lot of processing in Python because this
is you have to make each of the backends
easier to write we do a lot of stuff
essentially and then just farm out the
final results like well we're example
you know for very long lines if there's
like straight runs that are going to be
straight on the final plot we'll
simplify those and only have that in the
backend the reduced line the GPU people
don't want that at all what they want is
the whole line and they'll do the dance
sampling because you know the GPS are
extremely good at that so to get this
pie or gonna be or any of those plugged
in as a back-end right the first step is
like there's that you know there's like
ten functions they have to implement it
would and it would work but you'd lose a
lot of the benefit because we're still
doing so much from the Python side so
there'd have to be a little bit of
architecture internally to allow
backends to say no no I want the raw
stuff don't do any pre-processing so
there's a there's kind of a view of
where to do that but there's no there's
no resource to do that if you if you
have resource that you'd like to have do
that we'd love to talk to you any other
questions
you learn something that's pretty cool
to do guys know about the scant moving
the plot graph before yeah okay and
since I'm gonna show you one last demo
so this is the the work of our google
Summer of Code student if you look what
I'm putting into plot I'm putting in a
list of strings and it you know did the
right thing so all right cool thank you
so much